oh yeah do a clean meditation just like
you know just breathing I've done any
other things with shrooms as well to
where I went places but first time it
was just you know just me how long did
that take like oh it was like it was
about a few weeks a few weeks in you
know I I was meditating hard like one
week when I first learned how to I kind
of like became a professional I guess
just of me learning myself something
that everybody here is like yeah it's
probably something I should be doing but
nobody really knows how to like
effectively meditate in a way that's
like you know first thing we bring up an
interview damn here it's not superpower
yeah yeah
you can